invincible season one has just finished
and right after episode eight's release
amazon announced that they're moving
forward with seasons two and three of
the show
robert kirkman recently stated that he
wants to go all the way to season seven
and with just how popular it is it's
likely that we will be seeing
mark grayson on our screens for a long
time now the ending of episode 8 teases
towards a lot of things coming in the
future
and throughout this video we're going to
be giving our big predictions on what
will be happening in it
based off of the comics balls spoilers
ahead from this point
onwards so if you haven't had a chance
to check out the show then i highly
recommend that you check out now
if you enjoy it then please smash the
thumbs up button like nolan smashed his
son's face in
and subscribe for crap videos like this
every day without the way
welcome to the heavy hangover show
probably shouldn't have went out last
night but i'm here now
let's get into the breakdown okay so the
first thing i want to talk about in this
tease is the alien invaders who've shown
up throughout the series
when we last saw them nolan had entered
their dimension and he was destroying
everything in sight in the comics we
discovered that they are very much
terrified of him
and since his attack they've attempted
to rebuild their world
i'm guessing that the next spot of the
invasion will be what we open season 2
with
in the comics the majority of the arc
that we have just followed took place
over issues 1-13
the first year of the series culminated
with the fight between nolan and mark
which is how the show of course ends
year 2 starts in issue 14
and the story picks up with invincible
fighting alongside the guardians of the
globe
tackling the very forces that we see
here now the battle doesn't last too
long and it's actually in this in the
comics that the team discover that by
destroying the wrist straps and the
aliens
that they will rapidly age the show
changed things up to include this reveal
earlier on in the season
so i'm guessing that we will likely pick
up with one of the latter invasions
rather than having things just continue
to play out how they were
they also stab a screen with earth and
nolan's face on it
so it's likely that they're coming back
to get revenge now if mark doesn't have
enough trouble on his hands with them
the vulture mites and more trying to
invade
we've also got another invasion on top
of that
the sequids are still out in the galaxy
and after humanity traveled to the
planet
they managed to take over an astronaut
called russ livingston
in the series we discovered that a
native of mars had shape-shifted into
him
and in the comics he becomes a superhero
called shapesmith
who's basically a cross between plastic
man and martian manhunter
in issue 38 he ends up teaming up with
the guardians of the globe
and in 39 he divulges the history of the
sequoias
through him we discovered that they came
to mars in a damaged spaceship
centuries ago strange warriors emerged
from this craft
and waged war on the planet it was only
upon defeating these creatures that the
martians realized
it was actually the sacred parasites all
along
about who were behind it i'll stop doing
that crap joke now because of their
shape-shifting abilities
the segwits were unable to attach to the
martians however the martians found a
yeast for them
and because they operated with a hive
mind they were used to carry out slave
labor
over the years the martians experimented
on the creatures
and genetically modified them to be
stronger and faster
however bloody conspiracy theorists you
know what they're like
they started to think that the martian
government had lied about their origins
and that they were actually good
creatures that had been turned into
prisoners
an uprising on mars started and these
rebels wished to gain a life form that
the sequids could bond with
in order to free them however everyone
that came to the planet was
immediately executed thus shaped smith
who was part of this rebellion
took on the appearance of russ and the
rebels managed to stick a sequid on him
now as always with these bloody
conspiracy theorists
things didn't go to plan and the sequids
of course
took over the planet because they were
unable to attach to the martians
they instead enslaved them and in the
comics we watch as they travel to earth
in order to take over the planet the
guardians that are strong
enough not to be taken over by the
sequids travel into space
in order to stop them and they manage to
however the martians want to execute
shapesmith for his crimes and thus mark
and co end up playing with him
much like how he did with the astronauts
on mars now that's just a little funny
joke that they put in but i do like that
they called back to that moment
unfortunately whilst they're in space
the lizard league attack
and the other guardians have to take
them on but they're severely outmatched
there's actually a lot of big deaths
during this that i won't spoil here
but expect to see some of your favorites
taken out next time
now in flashes we can also catch dr
seismic
who is still alive in a special one-off
story called the pact
we discover that he's been lying low in
the earth's core
under the surface he's now worshipped as
a god by the creatures that lived there
which are called the magma knights now
mark goes down
and dukes it out with him but there's a
big twist when doc reveals that he's
actually happy that he fell into the
lava
seismic sees himself as being over the
hill someone who never made it to being
a big bad in his lifetime
and he knows that mark views him as one
of his lowly villains
however in this domain he's worshipped
as a god and
he quite enjoys living there marx seems
like he's happy for him
but he responds with an invincible punch
and knocks him out
elsewhere in the clips we also catch
titan who is now
fully set up as a crime boss mark of
course helped him to achieve this
position
and it's obvious that the two will be
coming face to face down the line
during the clip flashes in the episode
we do catch mr liu entering his office
and we discover in the comics that
there's actually a gang war going on
between him and titan
liu heads up a group known as the order
and they've been vying for control of
crime across the country
invincible ends up defeating lou in the
comics much like how he did titan
but i'm expecting a big episode focused
on that gang war
you also catch dia sinclair in the
finale working on new and improved
rihanna men
cecil looks over this and though there
are several possibilities that the plot
could go off into
personally i think it's going to be
something that pits mark against the gda
in the comics cecil becomes annoyed with
mark after he starts doing his own thing
he very much wants to keep him under
control and working for him
but mark constantly takes matters into
his own hands
cecil is someone who always has a
contingency plan
and after studying mark during the fight
with his father he discovers that
veltromites have a weakness
they can be heard by a high frequency
sound and cecil
unleashes this a mark before he gets the
reaniman to attack him
cecil believes that mark has gone rogue
and not wanting a repeat of what
happened with his father
he tries to take him out now whether
this will happen or not we don't know
yet
but the fact that the gda was studying
mark's blood
yeah i think it's pretty likely we also
catch battle beast who's out in space
doing what he does best and just killing
people
when we last saw him he was leaving
earth after mopping the floor with the
guardians
because the guy is an absolute badass
and in the comics we learned that after
he left earth he was captured and
imprisoned
allen the alien freed him but due to the
setup that we see in the show
i'm not sure if that will happen here he
did however join the forces of the
coalition
a group that allen is a member of who
were attempting to take the veltromites
down
battlebeast denied throughout that he
was actually helping the coalition
though
because the guy is such a badass now he
also goes head-to-head with the leader
of the veltromites at one point
who we discover is called drag he's
likely going to become
the big bad in the show and i really
hope that we're introduced to him
through battle beast
or as i call him badass beast now the
last thing i want to talk about
is what happened to nolan well in issue
25
science doug comes to meet mark in the
show this has been changed to say in
stock
but it's likely that they will keep this
plot element in place
now the dog says that he needs mark's
help and they travel across space to an
alien world
it's real that the dog is actually
wearing a costume and that it's really
an insect like alien
turns out it's been sent by mark's
father who is now ruling over this world
since failing his takeover of earth he's
done what he told mark he would
and the character has started again
somewhere else now mark just hugs his
dad upon seeing him
and you really hope that the pair can
rekindle their beautiful
beautiful totally not abusive father and
son relationship
however a big twist comes when nolan
reveals that he actually has another son
it also turns out that the vulturomite
scouts are coming to the planet
and mark and nolan have to team up and
work together in order to take them down
i think that's probably going to be how
season 2 ends and in my opinion it will
be the final episode
just makes sense to me to have them work
together so it reflects the ending of
the last season
i can't wait to see this moment play out
now there's so much to look forward to
with invincible
and what an incredible first season that
was you can't wait any longer then
definitely pick up the comics
as they're amazing and well worth
reading obviously there's a lot of
things that could happen in the season
so make sure you drop your theories and
predictions below
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 30th of may
in which we're giving away three copies
of the godzilla versus kong collection
all you have to do to be with a chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the show the
winners of last month's competition are
on screen right now
say that to you then message me on
twitter heavyspoilers if you want
somebody else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the
finale which will be linked on screen
right now
we've pointed out all the differences
from the comics where things line up and
the easter eggs so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
but out of the way thank you for
sticking through the video i've been
poor i'll see you next time
take care peace